facebook releases text-less nlp
roomba learns to avoid poop and jurgen
schmidt hoover invented every single
thing there is welcome to ml news it's a
great monday
all right let me show you something come
here watch this
see this is
one two three four boxes by kevin what
do these boxes contain
check it out it says
kevin
notes
do not throw away
and inside you'll just find like
a giant stack of papers there's four of
these boxes this
note-taking system works well for people
like kevin who is an organized and
diligent and conscientious person but
i'm not i could not do this and still
know what's going on in my research and
luckily i don't have to because uh
there's weights and biases that's
exactly for people like me who cannot
manage to keep up some sort of a manual
organized system weights and biases
tracks everything for me pretty much
automatically and always lets me know
what's going on in my research be that
for hyper parameter optimization or
within my data set or just as a log for
myself or for other people in form of a
weights and biases report so if you are
amazed how people can do this and if
you're like me and are absolutely unable
to do so maybe give weights and biases a
try because it's an absolute game
changer if you are a disorganized mess
and yeah that's pretty much all i have
to say to that check it out and see ya
hello and welcome to ml news on this
glorious monday let's dive into our
first story a popular ml youtuber has
just reached 100 000 subscribers this
historic milestone means that he's
probably going to get the silver play
button by youtube which is one of the
highest achievements one can reach in
life now here at ml news we are unbiased
we are neither pro nor con this
individual but legend says that the
paper review videos have been lacking
recently and also rumors are that his
mother is a hamster and his father
smells of elderberries
ml news has not been able to confirm or
reject this story but will keep track of
it
okay first real story facebook ai
releases a blog post on textless nlp
generating expressive speech from raw
audio this is essentially a language
model that goes directly from sound to
sound so previous works in these domains
have always first translated the sound
into text and then continued the text
and generated the sound again from that
but facebook has released three
successive papers that do away with the
text altogether going directly from the
sound wave to generating more sound and
not only that but they're able to do
this while capturing things like the
speaker's identity and the sort of
intonation and rhythm of the language
they do this unsurprisingly by using a
vq vae based system that teases apart
these individual things in the input
signal so the system is specifically
designed for speech and that makes it
really good at for example compressing
speech so what you do is you simply
transmit once your speaker identity
vector and then you transmit the latent
information that the model captures
about you to the receiver which is then
able to reconstruct your speech
including intonation rhythm and so on so
the system naturally doesn't have an
idea of what a token is in the language
so it works with what it calls
expressive units the expressive units
are something like tokens or syllables
but the model can essentially decide by
itself what they are so as i understand
it one expressive unit might be paw and
the other one might be ba and so on now
this opens up a lot of possibility you
can imagine taking a piece of speech and
changing its rhythm changing its
intonation changing its content changing
the speaker's identity while keeping the
rhythm and content but also these act as
real language models so you can give a
prefix spoken word and then have the
model continue that without the model
ever having trained on text so they have
some cool demonstrations in fact there's
an entire website of demonstrations
but it is a tendent from the people to
defend himself
from this information pride of the
potential
in criminal activity curiosity and
impetuosity of the world warsu acquired
and the model depending on the
temperature is capable of generating
something that actually sounds like real
speech so this is exciting because it
fulfills the end-to-end mentality that
deep learning promises and it pushes
this to this new domain of speech
without using the intermediate text
representation so hopefully this will
kick off an entirely new research
direction and we're excited to see what
happens
next news jurgen schmidt huber released
a new blog post called the most sighted
neural networks all build on work done
in my labs it's a relatively short blog
post that goes through sort of the
current state-of-the-art models and he
tries to argue that all of them somehow
come from work that he's done
undoubtedly jurgen schmidt uber has had
his fingers into a lot of research and
some of these claims are actually true
in the sense that it happened more than
once probably that he or people under
his supervision came up with ideas that
were a little bit before their time and
then other people adopted these ideas or
refined them and became much more
successful with them now that being said
he tends to push it a little bit too far
for example he's been long claiming that
his artificial curiosity principles is
essentially gans in a nutshell whereas
the general consensus is that it's not
like an obvious application of his ideas
and most recently claiming that fast
weight programmers are essentially
precursors to transformers now this can
be shown for a type of linear
transformer or linear retention
mechanism but that's essentially a
recurrent neural network but again to
see transformers as sort of the
incarnation of his ideas is a little bit
too far now in terms of the bigger
picture i've always appreciated schmidt
uber for sort of being the force that
tries to do justice to everyone that
tries to cite correctly and so on but
i'm not sure like a blog post called the
most cited neural networks all built on
work done in my labs might be pushing it
a little far but then what convinced me
that this is all correct is definitely
definitely the guns here like check this
got nothing on this we do a flexing
contest
this can be the thumbnail now this is a
good thumbnail
no he smiles
i need better light
[Music]
in any case i don't know what to make of
this i don't know who is served by a
blog post like this maybe it's just
meant as a little bit of an outlet for
himself but it's a free world so
who am i to tell him
the wall street journal ran an
investigation into how tick-tock's
algorithm works essentially what they've
done is they've created a lot of fake
profiles that went out and just watched
videos of a specific type of content
according to the hashtags of that
content and then they measured how fast
the algorithm picked up on their
interests and they found that the
algorithm extremely quickly rabbit holed
the individual users into their
preferred type of content which in this
case they give the example of depression
and mental health related content sort
of reinforcing all of that and then the
few videos in between that are not that
are a lot of advertisements and every
now and then kind of a video where the
algorithm tries to break you out of the
cycle tick tock is especially good at
this probably because the medium of
short videos lends itself a lot combined
with the interface it can measure how
long you watch each video and then serve
you more content according to that so
the wall street journal also interviews
a advocate for algorithm transparency
who explains a little bit what's going
on and if you're interested i invite you
to check out this article so what it
seems to be is that the tick tock
algorithm is essentially the youtube
algorithm on steroids and we've also
seen youtube become more and more crappy
over the years and by crappy i mean that
they've apparently traded off what
drives engagement versus the user
experience on the site now i know that
makes no sense like how can your user
experience be worse yet you engage more
with the content but that's what seems
to be happening now in the old days of
youtube the sidebar next to a video
actually contained relevant videos to
the one you were currently watching
there were video responses and other
things on that topic and increasingly
it's just become more and more
recommendation engine crap like yes i
know i generally watch pewdiepie's
videos but now i want to watch videos
about how car engines work please give
me stuff related to that and youtube
seem to have more and more just loaded
me with what it knows that i generally
like now there are some signs that in
recent times they've changed that up a
little bit which is a good thing but i
definitely miss the old days where you
could just sort of get lost in a topic
by just clicking videos on the sidebar
but safe to say these algorithms are a
difficult topic there's way too much
content so there has to be some kind of
an algorithm and of course these
platforms they want to make money so
it's natural that they would serve you
the thing that you engage with most but
i do agree with the person that wall
street journal interviews here and that
is that we often don't have enough
transparency in what happens behind
these algorithms why a particular thing
surfaced and what you can do to change
it cnn business rights the new iteration
of roomba uses ai to avoid smearing poop
all over your house apparently this is a
big problem that people have when using
their roomba that it catches feces of
pets and then just runs with it all
across the house now interestingly this
seems to be a very hard problem so the
company irobot the company behind the
roomba has spent years collecting data
related to poop so they had real poop
photos sent to them but they also model
all kinds of fake poop they bought
apparently all the funny fake poop that
you can find on the internet and they
made hundreds of play-doh poop models
and now they've trained the on-board
camera that was already trained to avoid
obstacles to also recognize feces and
steer around them and they're so
confident in that system that they said
they'll replace any of the new roombas
if they actually do catch poop so who
said ai couldn't be used to make the
world better excellent development
the nvidia blog has an article called an
ai for fine art attorney trains nvidia
rtx 2070 to authenticate masterpieces
now the nvidia article is based on this
article in ieee spectrum titled this ai
can spot an art forgery so this is about
how an amateur a lawyer by training
trained a convolutional neural network
to distinguish between real and fake
drawings so essentially the tough part
was collecting the data set of course
and for that he and his wife collected
numerous paintings by particular artists
but then also paintings by their
students and by people trying to imitate
their styles and they essentially
trained a classifier to distinguish
patches of the real images and patches
of the other images a big part of the
article is devoted on how to select the
patches that you train on and the
solution that this person came up with
is to look at the entropy of a
particular image patch and only include
image patches with high enough entropy
the result is sort of a heat map that
shows which parts of an image are likely
to be of the original artist and which
parts of the image are unlikely to be of
the original artist so they've applied
this to a data set of contested images
so they've evaluated 10 contested works
and in nine of them their system agrees
with the current scholarly opinion of
whether the painting is real or not and
of the one that isn't they say that they
hope that one day it will be
reconsidered and what's astounding to me
is that with such small data sets these
are
a handful or dozens of images made into
small patches so with such a small data
set and the basic approach of a cnn and
a heuristic of patch selection based on
entropy that this works at all this is
already astounding it's pretty cool but
then you cannot at the same time claim
that your system is good because it
agrees with nine out of ten expert
opinions and then also call for that
last one to be re-examined because the
system disagrees like either your system
is good because the human experts are
right or your system is so good that the
human experts aren't right in any case
the article details well how even an
amateur can use today's deep learning
methods in order to solve real world
problems or at least contribute a little
bit to the solution thereof one thing
that was funny i thought was how often
the nvidia blog post mentions the fact
that they are running a nvidia gpu to do
this so this is accelerated by an nvidia
gpu really
what gpu this gpu and frank reports his
nvidia gpu dramatically speeds up their
work allowing them to train models in
hours that used to take days time
difference is just mind-boggling sorry i
didn't realize this was nvidia ads it
said nvidia blog at the top but you know
business insider writes inside
deepmind's secret plot to break away
from google ml news has reported on this
previously but yet another article
giving more details into how deepmind
pretty much immediately after
acquisition already had plans to not be
controlled by google so the article
details how deepmind wanted to set up
some sort of a non-profit structure and
then a cap profit structure and then
some sort of system that the ai they
produce isn't controlled by google and
the reasons they give are things like ai
ethics and who will control the ai and
this shouldn't be in the possession of a
single entity and blah blah blah like
i i get it right you needed the money so
you went to google but i'm not sure how
you know how acquisition works like they
pay for it they get it and i don't
believe all this crap of we want the
best for humankind no no you're one of
the most secretive ai research labs
there is you hardly publish any models
any code you are forced to do so for
alpha fold but everything else is still
a secret you often publish in paywall
journals so no i don't believe any of
this so yeah i'm sorry you sold your
company and now it's no longer yours
in related news fast company rights
ex-googlers raise 40 million dollars to
democratize natural language ai this is
about a startup called cohere and
apparently has the backing of jeffrey
hinton and fei-fei li and much like a
lot of others of these startups it
promises to democratize ai to give more
people access to it and so on so on
their website you can sign up for the
wait list to their api but it seems that
it's essentially the same as many of the
other language model apis where they
have the model and they let you use it
according to their terms of service and
how exactly that is different i'm not
entirely sure yet
the register writes only natural persons
can be recognized as patent inventors
not ai systems a us judge rules so this
is an addendum to a story that we've
previously covered about stephen taller
getting a patent on an invention that
his ai has invented so he's the owner
but the ai is listed as the inventor and
this has been accepted in south africa
and australia as far as i can remember
but now a us judge has rejected the
patent in the us and the reason seems to
be that the computer program doesn't fit
the definition of an individual that
must take an oath to swear that they are
the inventor on a patent application
taller on his side says he wants to
continue to fight for inventor rights of
his machines primarily to prevent humans
from stealing ideas generated by
computers and taking all the credit if
there was ever a first world problem i
guess this is one
in a q a sam altman said apparently that
gpt-4 will remain text only it will be
apparently not much bigger than gpt-3
but a lot more compute will have gone
into it he claims that it's astounding
how far you can get with simply using
more compute and doing smarter things
gpt 4 therefore will be a more powerful
language model but not necessarily
larger which is good news and maybe
these techniques that openai uses to
make gpt4 better can be applied to even
smaller models though whether or not
openai will actually release all of
these tricks is yet to be seen altman
apparently also said that the focus
right now is on a new release of codex
which i guess open air realizes is a
better business case than large language
models
in very related news salesforce releases
code t5 the code aware encoder decoder
based pre-trained programming language
models shouldn't this say model
yeah here it says model see so this is a
version of t5 that is specifically
trained on code and even more
specifically it is trained on a bunch of
subtasks around code so next to the
masked span predictions which you know
from language model there's also masked
identifier prediction where the model
needs to come up with essentially
variable names there is identifier
tagging there is generation you can
generate descriptions from code and code
from descriptions and all of this
results in a model that is very good on
these code generation tasks so there's a
lot of things happening in bringing
language model into the world of coding
and it's looking out to be an exciting
time and the cool thing is code and
pre-trained models are available
some helpful things i've come across
this week deepmind releases their
reinforcement learning lecture series
this is a series of youtube videos along
with slides that you can watch and
download and they take you from zero to
hero on reinforcement learning starting
off with exploration and control and
mdps and ending on deep reinforcement
learning so if you've always wanted to
get into rl this is a very up-to-date
resource to do so also deepmind releases
the wiki graphs data set along with
tools to download it now haven't i
complained earlier that deepmind
releases nothing i might want to tone
down that criticism a little bit so
here's a repo that lets you download the
wiki graphs dataset which links
wikipedia articles to freebase entries
and the hope is that people will develop
new language models and methodologies
that make use of the graph structures of
how these entities are linked together
another cool data set is the live cell
data set which is a large scale data set
for label
live cell segmentations so this is a big
data set for segmenting cells in these
microscopy images very cool check it out
and lastly a cool library called speech
brain a pie torch powered speech tool
kit that helps you with various tasks
around speech processing if you're
interested in that
all k-pop writes social media influencer
model created from artificial
intelligence lens 100 sponsorships so
this is about rosie which is this avatar
right here now i'm not exactly sure i
think rosie is like a 3d model that they
render into real pictures not entirely
sure how it works but given that this
looks a little bit like current pixar
movies but the backgrounds look
relatively real i think that's what's
happening so there's a company behind
rosie and they sell rosie as a model so
you can book rosie and rosie will do
advertisements for you the ceo says the
reason for the popularity of virtual
humans is that there is no fear that
advertisements will be suspended due to
unsavory privacy scandals after the ai
model is selected as the advertising
model also the virtual model is not
limited in time and space unlike real
people now you just wait for that
the way ai is currently progressing
pretty soon will have scandals involving
not real people but ais i guess we have
that right now already so
you know
okay it's time for news questions which
is where i answer questions asked by the
news without reading the article here we
go forbes asks artificial intelligence
should you teach it to your employees no
mindmatters asks isn't it time for an
artificial intelligence reality check no
fortune asks did deep mind just make a
big step towards more human-like ai no
forbes asks is artificial intelligence
set to take over the art industry no
cnbc asks are our fears of artificial
intelligence justified no kcrw asks can
alexa tackle the meaning of life
no techcrunch asks ai as a service to
solve your business problems
nope and forbes again asks how do we use
artificial intelligence ethically
probably the same way you use a knife
just don't stab anyone with it
our final news for today the verge
writes automated hiring software is
mistakenly rejecting millions of viable
job candidates so the article describes
a new report from harvard business
school saying that a lot of people who
would match a job description are
screened out by ai now rather than this
being a big criticism of these systems i
think this is a big cry for the use of
technology it seems like most of the
errors that these systems make are
because they're just not good enough and
because they work on like stupid
handcrafted rules like it searches for
exact matches of certain skills in the
cvs of applicants rather than
considering synonyms of these skills or
it has hard filters like if you've had a
certain time of pause between your
employments then you're automatically
screened out rather than going into the
reason why you had to pause during that
time i think there's a lot of potential
here to make technology more accurate in
order to help these companies make
hiring easier and they need it it's not
like they do this just to save money the
article details this saying that in the
early 2010s the average corporate job
posting attracted 120 applicants but by
the end of the decade this figure had
risen to 250 applicants per job so it's
not like this is a problem that you
could just easily solve by doing it
yourself it's not like a lot of these
companies are lazy it's just that the
amount of data they'd have to analyze
manually is just too much and even if
you let humans do it if you just
overwhelm humans with giant amounts of
applications they're gonna do exactly
the same thing well this person's skill
doesn't exactly match out well this
person had some unexplained break out i
don't have time to research why this
happened so i think the potential for
machines to improve and deliver better
service here is pretty good and probably
one of the better shots we have at
solving this problem rather than just
dooming all hiring technology altogether
i'm not saying there aren't problems
with these kinds of technologies just
saying we could make them more useful
cool that was it for ml news thank you
so much for watching subscribing and
i'll see you next time bye bye
[Music]